it was really shunned on in the church  when i played a child prostitute but my  mom would come to church and like have  this testimony speech written where she  would then go stand up on the stage and  talk about how like this is actually a  really good thing for the church because  it might lead to prostitutes hearing the  whisper of the holy ghost if they see  this and they know that jeanette's  mormon like they might convert as well  like she had a really charming kind of  side to her personality even though she  was saying insane things most of the  time well sounds like she might have  been a smart cookie you know she had a  capacity for intelligence and i feel  like it was wasted and i feel like she  didn't really use it for good and it  upsets me